so guys here we go
dubai mall do some stuff watch some
people fly the and then we're gonna go
to the helicopter there but you can't
join us in helicopters just just fine
we just clean the windows normally they
have its Capaldi they don't they're just
repelling that not I'd love to show a
video here ice skating ring all that
where I am we were looking for a roller
coaster in the aquarium itself giant on
the outside but you can't a like a
conveyor belt on the inside actually
walked through the entire aquarium oh my
god
this is amazing taste Gary five me he's
gonna hear the glass here in this small
way is actually a little bit thinner
glass out there because it's using the
structural integrity of an arch
we have a lot of events scheduled we
need to go to the drone racetrack on but
we also need to be at the helicopter
field by 3:00 and it's already 1:30 so
we're running out of time yeah organizer
hello everyone hi welcome to Dubai thank
you I'm the biopic I had the peasant
time coming here absolutely
it was raining a few days ago yeah you
came and you brought the sunshine thank
you would you give you a brief on why
we're doing this technology can be used
to make it a lot better
it's here it's going very fast we'll
make it exciting for the gen-pop ok this
is absolutely incredible
who should we think on this yes the
organizers of the world drunk gaming
these are the pilot seats someone
sitting in one of these chairs will win
two hundred thousand dollars tomorrow
isn't this so real quick
I assume he knows we're gone look what I
got on we don't have cash yeah we are
running late hopefully we can get there
on time and not miss our helicopter I
mean I wouldn't mind I know you wouldn't
mind cuz you're terrified of heights
she's already dangerous being on broke
why do we need to go into the sky
fortunately I am looking forward to it
and I'm looking forward to seeing your
misery legitimately I do not we made it
we just got
the window
I want to really make this disclaimer
very crystal clear I feel really bad for
what happens if I might